so there's been a new leak doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness tv
spot and with that there's been some new
footage and dialogue so let's break it
down so the trailer begins with a single
piano note and it kind of has a horror
undertone and as that note plays you see
doctor strange place his hand on an
actual piano it then cuts to a wide shot
and then you see sheets of piano notes
falling from the air doctor strange then
stops these pieces of paper from falling
and then seems to cast a spell of some
kind we then cut a new footage of wonder
and a new dialogue line where she says
in the multiverse every nightmare has
become a reality now this new footage of
wanda is actually very very interesting
now this is one to remember in her
birthday which she had when she was
younger but to be honest i think this is
actually a part of a nightmare she's
having just where everything is shot and
just the way wonder is reacting it's
like she's having a vision of this or
this is a nightmare even in the picture
frame it looks like wonder herself could
actually be moving and as we know
obviously things are moving pictures
they're just a still image so this just
makes me think this is part of an iron
man and even with the dialogue in the
background she says every nightmare so
it kind of just makes me lead to believe
this is a nightmare sequence we then
have a quick new shot of wonder in the
mirror dimension and then we see the
last new shot of this tv spot and it is
a new shot of doctor strange handcuffs
inside of the illuminati headquarters
and he is walking towards them this is
why i imagine he will meet professor x
anyway that's about it for this
breakdown so if you guys did enjoy
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys